you have advice for young people about
career about life people in high school
people in college
of um how to live a life they can be
proud of
so i what i like to do is tell people
don't plan it because i didn't plan
anything everything i did was one step
at a time you don't have to plan
i just
found things that were interesting to me
and so i
my father was a doctor and
he wanted me to be a doctor but i was
not interested in
taking care of people i
learned that
but i couldn't say no to him so
you know i was a biology major in
college and i i graduated and
i didn't have anything to do
so i liked science so i got a job in the
lab
and it was very exciting and
that led
to everything else that i've done one
step at a time and i think
the most important thing you can do well
they're two important things you could
be really curious all the time you
mentioned curiosity i think curiosity is
essential
you have to be curious about everything
and if you are you're never going to be
bored yeah
and so people who say they're bored i
say you are not curious you should just
think about things and say look at
something and say how does that work or
what what is it doing and how do they
get there and you'll never be bored and
the other thing is when you find
something
which may take time
it's fine
you have to be passionate about it you
have to put everything into it
and that's what i did with viruses so
i i think they're amazing and
i tell my classes
i love viruses they're amazing and
people think i'm morbid because
obviously they kill they kill people and
i shouldn't love something that but
that's not the point that's not what i
mean i love them in the way they have
emerged and
how they work and and so forth and all
that we don't know about them so you
need to be curious and passionate and
don't plan too much and just find
something
that you don't call a job
because someone said on the live stream
last week i wish i had a job i i liked
as much as you i said it's not a job i
never looked at it as a job it's my
vocation it's my passion
if it's a job then you're not gonna like
it yeah something that doesn't feel like
a job
you